[Music]
taxpayers still paying Robert tellis's
salary he is the elected official
accused of killing a reporter who
exposed problems under his leadership
tell us then lost the Democratic primary
eight news now investigator Vanessa
Murphy in court this morning has more
about the effort to remove him from his
position the Clark County District
Attorney's office is seeking to remove
Robert Kellis from his position even
though he's in jail accused of murder he
still is the Clark County public
administrator and he's still getting
paid do you understand the charge Robert
tell us appearing in court briefly
Tuesday morning as the DA's Office
charges him in connection with the
murder of review journal investigative
journalist Jeff gearman D.A Steve
Wolfson says his staff is also asking a
judge in civil court to remove the
elected official from his seat right now
Telus is still getting paid his 120
thousand dollar salary she can't before
if he's neglectful in his job he should
be removed Telus has been in custody
since September 7 and is being held
without bail until at least his next
court appearance on October 26th we
tried asking Tellus if he'd resign after
we learned about the DA's effort to
remove him from office he refused to sit
down with us after his court appearance
Telus will now be represented by the
Clark County Public Defender's Office
reporting in downtown Las Vegas at the
Regional Justice Center Vanessa Murphy 8
News Now